zu viele flüchtlinge der faktencheck zur
flüchtlingskrise was ist mit unserer
wertegemeinschaft in deutschland und ist
migration teil unserer gesellschaft das
sind heute die themen bei pixum science
fiction
genau auf 476 1649 476 1649 asylanträge
gab es im jahr 2015 in deutschland so
viel wie noch nie und ist das viel
verändert sich die deutsche kultur
dadurch seit dem letzten jahr seit
angela merkels berühmte wir schaffen das
ist dass das reizthema die frage nach
der obergrenze steht im raum
aber migration völkerwanderung flucht
das sind alles keine neuen probleme die
es erst 2015 gibt menschen wandern schon
immer aus den unterschiedlichsten
gründen aus ihrer heimat aus manche aus
zwang manche freiwillig im vergleich zum
vorjahr ist die zahl der asylanträge
tatsächlich in deutschland explodiert
2014 waren es noch rund 200.000 2015
knapp eine halbe million aber nicht
jedem antrag wird stattgegeben so
ungefähr jeder zweite bekommt in
deutschland den status eines flüchtlings
zugesprochen
aber was heißt das überhaupt dieser
status bezieht sich auf die genfer
flüchtlingskonvention von 1951 ins leben
gerufen wurde
in dieser werden den hilfesuchenden
rechte aber auch pflichten zugesprochen
zunächst sollte sie die flüchtlinge
schützen die durch den zweiten weltkrieg
auf der flucht waren und war zunächst
auf europa begrenzt im jahr 1967 wurde
die konvention um ein protokoll
erweitert dass die zeitliche und
geografische beschränkung der ersten
fassung aufhob das abkommen sieht vor
dass menschen die aufgrund ihrer rasse
nationalität religion politischer
ansichten oder einer bestimmten sozialen
gruppenzugehörigkeit verfolgt werden
schutz geboten wird 146 staaten auf der
welt haben das abkommen über die
rechtsstellung der flüchtlinge
unterzeichnet laut der un reggie agency
kurz whtr wurden bisher 50 millionen
menschen durch das abkommen vor
verfolgung geschützt wie sieht es
eigentlich mit dem deutschen haus auch
die wandern ja aus immer wenn es in der
deutschen geschichte zu konflikten
gekommen ist flohen viele verfolgte
unter anderem in die vereinigten staaten
von amerika also zum beispiel 48 49 zum
scheitern der deutschen revolution kam
wanderten viele menschen in die usa oder
nach australien aus passend zur jahres
war wurden diese forty eight hours
genannt der wahlspruch viel
war damals die lieber das ibi patria was
übersetzt bedeutet wo die freiheit ist
dort ist mein vaterland
bezieht man dies auf die aktuelle
flüchtlingskrise stellt sich die frage
was ein land und was heimat ausmacht
nüchtern betrachtet ist anstatt erst mal
ein abgegrenztes stück erde in dem
gewisse regeln gelten auch wird in
diesem zusammenhang auch von
wertegemeinschaft gesprochen diese werte
und die kultur sind das resultat von
jahrhundertelangen menschlichen
zusammenleben mit all seinen höhen und
tiefen kriege prägen das werte bild
genauso wie wissenschaftlicher
fortschritt aber auch die konservative
rückbesinnung auf das was vorher schon
da war die errungenschaften die eine
nation geprägt haben lassen sich nur
schwer in zeitliche abschnitte
unterteilen die bundesrepublik wurde
maßgeblich vom dritten reich geprägt
daraus resultiert zb dass die bundeswehr
keine angriffs armee sein kann aber auch
der europäische grundgedanke das sind
die lehren dieser zeit lebt man noch
weiter zurück wird man feststellen dass
unsere kultur auch stark vom islam und
dem nahen osten geprägt wurde ganz
offensichtlich denn das christentum das
kommt ja nun mal nicht aus europa
sondern eben aus dem nahen ostens hat
sich hier allerdings prägend
weiterentwickelt und die etabliert und
auch der islam
der hat seine spuren in europa
hinterlassen und das schon im siebten
und achten jahrhundert einerseits durch
viele eroberungen zum beispiel auch
teile spaniens wie man heute noch an der
alhambra in granada sehen kann
die im 13 jahrhundert errichtet wurde
aber auch zum beispiel in italien finden
sich einflüsse islamischer architektur
auf wissenschaft und philosophie fanden
so einen aufschwung im mittelalter
europas wohlgemerkt der islam ist
mitverantwortlich für die entwicklung
zur heutigen europäischen kultur und
wissenschaft was wir also heute als
wertegemeinschaft verstehen enthält
viele teile dieser geschichte es lässt
sich nicht geografisch abgrenzen
wir haben nur eine gewisse vorstellung
was die wertegemeinschaft bedeutet und
da es sich bei der bundesrepublik um
eine demokratie handelt ist der immer
neue findungsprozess auch gewollt es
soll mehrere meinungen die gesetze geben
uns einen gewissen rahmen vor
die ethik und moral lässt sich bei
vielen dingen bestimmt auch auf einen
kleinen gemeinsamen
unterbrechen aber die varianz ist doch
recht groß also die verschiedenen
vorstellungen und ideen wie ethik und
moral auszusehen haben sonst gäbe es die
diskussion um die zuwanderung nicht man
darf nicht vergessen dass die
gleichberechtigung der frauen noch nicht
so lange bei uns standard ist und dass
sie noch lange nicht wirklich umgesetzt
worden ist ich denke zum beispiel an die
unterschiedliche bezahlung von männern
und frauen
dass es immer noch ein ziemlicher
skandal oder der paragraf 175 der sex
unter männern unter strafe stellte wurde
erst 1994 aufgehoben bis vor kurzem war
also homosexualität in deutschland noch
unter bestimmten bedingungen strafbar
schlimm die geschichte der menschheit
ist geprägt durch auswanderung ob
europäer vor dem anfall der und fliehen
juden sich vor verfolgung in sicherheit
bringen oder deutsche in den usa bessere
perspektiven sehen und es gibt dort ganz
tolle beispiel also in den usa von
städten in denen die ursprüngliche
bevölkerung heute in der minderheit ist
und trotzdem alle prima zusammen leben
die usa sind auch das beste beispiel für
eine migranten nation
erinnern wir uns noch an die zahl vom
anfang 476 1649 asylanträge in
deutschland bis vier einsätze wie das
boot ist voll aber platz deutschland
wirklich aus allen nähten
wie viele deutsche verlassen eigentlich
das land selbst
laut dem sachverständigenrat deutscher
stiftungen für integration und migration
kurz svr verlassen vor allem junge und
qualifizierte menschen deutschland 70
prozent der auswanderer sind
hochqualifiziert von 2009 bis 2013 zogen
rund 710.000 deutsche ins ausland im
gleichen zeitraum nur 580.000 zurück die
meisten sorgen übrigens in die schweiz
und die usa
natürlich handelt es sich bei den
deutschen auswandern und menschen die
sich frei entschieden haben das land zu
wechseln ganz anders sieht es bei dem
rund 60 millionen menschen weltweit aus
die keine andere perspektive haben und
irland aufgrund von krieg oder
verfolgung verlassen müssen
die anzahl der personen innerhalb des
bundesgebietes wächst mit dem flüchtigen
also nicht wirklich bemerkenswert an und
nur zwei prozent aller flüchtlinge
weltweit kommen nach deutschland
für experten ist migration schon seit
jahren teil der deutschen kultur
auch wenn es meistens nur unterbewusst
war
die vielfalt sei zb in vielen firmen ein
gewollter faktor von dem man profitieren
kann
vor allem wenn man international
erfolgreich sein will damit die
integration der menschen weiter
funktioniert liegt es am start für
genügend soziale gerechtigkeit zu sorgen
die rechte und pflichten für die
menschen klar aufzuzeigen aber auch die
prozesse zu optimieren
denn ein wirklich großes problem ist
weiterhin die langsame bearbeitung der
asylanträge auf die medien haben ihren
anteil am gelingen oder eben nicht
gelingen der integration einigen
etablierten medien gelingt es mit
reißerische überschriften immer wieder
misstrauen und angst zu verbreiten
dies bietet dann einen hervorragenden
nährboden für die rechte und
rechtskonservative szene die die lage
für sich gut zu nutzen weiß und zeigt
wie verschieden die vorstellung in der
wertegemeinschaft deutschland doch sein
können die letzte große flüchtlingswelle
fand übrigens in den 1990 er jahren
statt auch damals schnellte die zahl der
asylanträge auf 400.000 hoch im jahr
1992 zeigte die wertegemeinschaft
deutschland allerdings auch ihr
hässlichstes gesicht als in der
zentralen aufnahmestelle für flüchtlinge
in rostock lichtenhagen besorgte bürger
tagelang bürgerkriegsartigen zuständen
auslösten es kam damals so weit dass das
gebäude in dem sich auch kinder
aufhielten mit molotow-cocktails in
brand gesteckt wurde und teilweise
gestürmt wurde
damals kam es zum versagen der
polizeikräfte ähnlich wie man es ihnen
nun beim vorfall in der silvesternacht
in köln vorwirft
aus dem vergleich der beiden situation
lässt sich erkennen wie wichtig es ist
dass der staat in der lage sein muss die
soziale lage
ob es sich nun um nordafrikaner oder und
besorgte deutsche handelt richtig
einzuschätzen und vorher die bedingungen
schaffen muss damit das zusammenleben
aller gut verlaufen kann
dazu gehört zum einen zum beispiel die
soziale gerechtigkeit und zum anderen
eine vernünftige integrationspolitik wie
positiv sich aber auch das engagement
der bürger also von uns auswirkt das
zeigen die zahlreichen berichte aus den
letzten wochen wir positiv aufgenommen
wird der ist auch gerne bereit sich in
die gesellschaft zu integrieren
und positiv an der gestaltung der
zukunft teilzunehmen
natürlich muss darf und soll zum thema
zuwanderung kritisch diskutiert werden
nur weil migration teil der
menschheitsgeschichte und zumindest in
diesen zeiten und vermeidbar ist können
die herausforderungen nicht
totgeschwiegen werden
sie ist sogar eine chance sich der
probleme durch fehlende soziale
gerechtigkeit bewusst zu werden und so
auch auf anderen gebieten für positive
entwicklung für alle menschen innerhalb
der gesellschaft zu sorgen
ich frage bei diesem video absolut offen
was meint ihr schreibt in die kommentare
beschimpft euch nicht und lasse gerne
abo da das ist ganz wichtig kostenlos
schaut auch noch die anderen videos vom
kanal an es gibt hier unglaublich viele
spannende themen und ansonsten bis zum
nächsten mal
bis dann bleibt dran